knowing that you may be rushed into
making your first feature film and you
have a lot of things that you would have
done differently do you think it's
better that you did that
rather than still be talking about
making that feature film ten years out
no it was the right decision to make
like I don't I don't fault you know I
don't regret having done the film it was
really exciting I still watch it every
now and then and I'm like oh good this
is actually like a good little feel I'm
still excited about it but what I think
that the realization that I have come to
is in order to cook the meal that you
need to cook you need to have all the
ingredients on the table and so now I'm
taking a much more realistic approach
for but with budget I'm taking a more
realistic I'm still not in the million
dollar you know range but I am at the
place where I know that a certain level
of professionalism that I need a certain
level of talent that I need and so to
approach work now with a little bit more
savvy and making sure I have those
ingredients is a little bit more
important but I'm glad that I cooked the
film that I cooked the first time and
I'm very glad that I did that because I
wouldn't be here had I not gone through
that process so the the the film wasn't
burnt but it it could have used maybe
more than raw spiced cake that didn't
rise that was doable okay but you can't
serve it to the master okay I know I
mean as a metaphorical that's we could
be you know it just didn't rise to the
level that I felt like it could have
risen to with a little bit better
ingredients that I needed to have along
the way but it was a great I think it's
still I still think it was a great
project what prompts you to watch it
over and over again sometimes you just
need to be reminded I think a lot of
times with creators because we're always
focused on what's next we forget what
we've done and I think when you forget
what you've done you lose sight of where
how much you've grown so like I can
watch my films and I see elements in my
first film that are gonna be in my new
film that I'm gonna be doing
like I still do the color-coding like I
still approach scenes kind of in a
similar way but a more progressed play
than I used to in the past I still want
to throw these little nuggets of life
inside the dialog I still do some of the
same elements so it's nice to see that
what I made was a true depiction of Who
I am as a creator and as a person and
but but it also lets me know the
resources and the skill set that I was
at that time so sometimes you're trying
to be reminded that you have made
progress you have to see where you've
been to be able to recognize where
you're going I heard you say in a talk
that you gave somewhere in New York
there's a great talk and you said you
have to know that you want to be part of
this industry do you think people really
have to know or can they just kind of
like you know try it out and see where
it takes you is it okay to be on the
fence about it or do you really have to
know that you want to be in this
industry
well I liken it to climb in Mount
Kilimanjaro either you're gonna climb
Mount Kilimanjaro or you're not you
can't decide the day before climbing the
mountain that you're going to climb the
mountain that's how people die on the
mountain but if you know this is what
your actual goal is then you have to put
the work in to prepare yourself for it
and a lot of that is nothing that could
be taught in a film school nothing that
could even really be learned on film
courage it is an actual experience that
you have to have to understand who you
are how you are because the house really
matter in this approach of making films
and being part of this industry so I
think people have to know is 100% what
they want to do but there's also a
little bit of beauty in the the bliss of
ignorance because had I known all of
what I would have had to suffer to get
to this very moment that I am now I
would not have done this now I wouldn't
know I wouldn't have done it I didn't
know that there was so much suffering as
that's part of a creative journey in the
industry that I find to be so beautiful
because it's that hard it's literally
climbing Mount Kilimanjaro
but I know how to scale Mount
Kilimanjaro now because I've had so many
experiences and I've been training for
so long so I feel like now I'm in LA I'm
ready to be a part of this industry I
know who I am as a creator I know how to
work with other creatives I know how to
take through your notes now like I know
the difference between a television
directing and film directing like I
understand these things now and I needed
all those small experiences to get
exactly where I am right now but if I
had the foresight I wouldn't have done
it has this been that difficult what do
you think you would have done I'm not
sure I think I would've been a teacher I
love to like teach and like share
knowledge and information and I think
that's what my films are they're just
really beautiful lessons you know that
people get to see and participate in so
I probably would have been a teacher I
think I pretty but it hump it up an okay
teacher yeah I think because that we saw
you giving like a lecture to a group of
filmmakers yeah and you know you had
high energy and just know we're willing
to admit where he went wrong doing
things and but I just wondered if you'd
ever envisioned what would have happened
if you knew how hard it would have been
I don't know I think again I just used
the macula maduro thing I think even
people who have successfully scaled the
mountain still didn't realize that would
be a difficult as what it was and I
think to still get to the top and I
recognize how difficult and what it was
is where the joy comes in right that's
what makes the hero's journey because
I'm on my own hero's journey trying to
come from nothing to make myself
relevant in an industry that I am
extremely passionate about and that I
love so yeah but I would I wouldn't I
wouldn't do it if I could see it if I
could see it I wouldn't have done it did
your family ever call you to come home
no they know they knew calling me to try
to come back to Arkansas would be
totally futile they would never make
that call in there was a lot of
trepidation for them I mean to live in
Arkansas is to live in such a safe space
you know
take much to own a home there's a
community people that already support
that already love but the reality is the
industry I want to be a part of the
existing Agora and in exist in LA so I
had to make the decisions to come to
come out here and I'm glad I did
you